[Music]
one of the greatest bottlenecks in the
area of gene therapy is delivery
if you can't deliver a therapeutic
payload into a diseased cell
they sort of have no hope of curing that
cell in any meaningful way
and so in attempting to solve this
problem we are highly inspired by
viruses
which through the process of evolution
have developed elegant methods by which
to infiltrate host cells and one method
used by a certain class of viruses that
infect bacteria
called bacteriophages and here's a
little bacteriophage virus
and so these phages utilize this really
elegant macromolecular syringe device
and here's this kind of syringe
structure
beneath the capsid of the virus and they
use these syringes to
sort of directly puncture their host
membranes
and this device is known as a
contractile injection system this kind
of syringe structure
in a manner similar to the action of a
virus injecting its genome into a host
cell
we are developing contractile injection
systems capable of injecting therapeutic
proteins directly into human cells
and through this project we first
successfully purified a novel
contractile injection system
from a laboratory organism e coli we
next show that the system is capable
injecting large protein cargoes into
cultured eukaryotic cells
finally we're currently reprogramming
the system for injection against
cultured human cells
with the ultimate intention of
developing safe and specific therapeutic
delivery devices
with these contractile injection systems
to enable the next generation of gene
[Music]
therapy